in 1974 the people of cyprus had their
country invaded turks have lost patience
have given up words in favor of war
and now almost 50 years later the island
is experiencing a second invasion
but these invaders don't want land they
don't want money or power
they aren't even turks or greeks or
british
they're donkeys
[Music]
they've been here a long time
[Music]
i want to tell you about these donkeys
but first i want to thank today's
sponsor who supported my trip to cyprus
and supports this channel generally so
thank you bright sellers for supporting
bright sellers is a company that sent me
a box of wine
and this wasn't just any old random box
of wine this was a box of bottles of
wine that were chosen for me based on a
quiz that i took and then my favorite
part is that each of these bottles comes
with an education card that provides
serving and pairing tips it gives some
background on the wine and it allows you
to have a much more like educated
tasting experience
for me wine becomes way better when you
actually have a story behind it you
actually have understanding of what's
going on with the wine and what it pairs
with and all of that the cool thing is
you can do this from the comfort of your
couch you don't have to go anywhere
bright cellars is all online and again
they ship it to your house
and then you can rate and give feedback
on the wines that you like to better
hone the algorithm so they know what to
send you it's literally like the spotify
discover tab but for wine brightsellers
is so confident that you're going to be
paired with the right wines because of
this quiz and process that if you don't
like the wine they'll literally send you
a replacement bottle in your next box
if you want to try this out
brightsellers is offering 60
off your first four bottle box that's 38
for these four bottles not each like for
the whole box it's 38 bucks
there's a link in my description go
click that link and take the quiz to get
started and get 60 off your first box of
bright sellers wine thank you bright
sellers for supporting this work and now
let's get back to cypress to talk about
donkeys
i'm in cyprus and i am looking at a lot
of
donkeys
[Music]
all over this island
there are tons of donkeys they are just
everywhere
[Music]
these donkeys don't belong to anyone
they don't have a
farm that they're working
they don't have a home besides the wild
they stop traffic they're on the road
they just don't care they just
they just don't they're just so stubborn
and they just sit there and there's like
hey cool your car
inevitably comes the question
what are these donkeys and how on earth
did they get here
the answer to that question
like every other part of this series
has to do with the conflict
tanks of the turkish army on the
outskirts of famagusta are about to
complete their victory in cyprus they
will take what they want of cyprus by
force of arms
so we're now in episode three of this
series and hopefully you're familiar
with the story of this island by now to
summarize in 1974 the turkish government
invaded the northern part of cyprus in
that process all of the greek cypriots
who lived in the north fled to safety in
the south and all of the turkish
cypriots in the south fled to safety in
the north the greek cypriots who were up
here fled and left their farms empty
their homes empty their churches empty
but they didn't take the donkeys with
them
there weren't that many at that point
but the donkeys started wandering the
countryside finding food then they
started mating
not having a natural predator of any
kind so they started proliferating
classic invasive species type situation
so modern-day cypress is a pretty
advanced place but not too long ago
these places were agrarian societies
[Music]
for thousands of years cyprus has been
the home to farming to a serious amount
of farming whenever there
is food and livelihood some of the best
olive oil production on earth
historically has happened here
in cyprus
they've grown olives and all sorts of
fruit in cyprus for longer than anyone
has written harsh history so i'm trying
to read my lines guys for this video i'm
making so could you just sort of give me
a minute
could you give me a minute thanks
these are the recently introduced john
deere 55 series even in the 1970s when
tractors were normalized around the
world owning a tractor in cyprus was
actually very difficult
this was an island in the middle east it
was difficult to import stuff here
so the farmers stuck to what they had
been doing for literally thousands of
years using animals to do their farm
work
horses were expensive and not very
abundant and so donkeys were the answer
in 1974 when the turks invaded the north
it was estimated that there were two
donkeys on average for every farming
household
and with one third of the island's
population being farmers that means a
lot of donkeys
donkeys were the powerhouse that would
help pull plows or run mills that would
make olive oil
so after this mass exodus from the north
these donkeys were left abandoned
orphaned by the conflict so
there's donkeys everywhere
why is that a problem again is that a
problem well it wasn't a problem for a
while until the donkeys proliferated so
much that there ended up being thousands
of them here in northern cyprus
it started to become an issue when the
donkeys started showing up to farms and
pulling up all of the crops and eating
them
it's like the revenge of the donkeys
they're like you left us out to dry when
it was war time we're coming back to to
get revenge no but seriously this became
like a real issue for the farmers in
this region who are just like i i don't
need wild donkeys messing with my crops
[Music]
so the natural response for a lot of
people was why don't we just hunt these
donkeys and just
thin out the population by hunting them
but after one group of donkeys was found
dead
there was a big backlash and in fact a
backlash that brought greek cypriots and
turkish cypriots together in an unlikely
moment of collaboration and cooperation
animal rights activists on both sides of
the border got together and lobbied for
a law that would make it illegal to kill
donkeys and in fact would come with a
seven-year prison penalty if you kill
the donkey if you have a hard time
understanding why these donkeys have
protected status and why you'll go to
jail for seven years if you kill one
that's because you don't understand
cyprus's connection to donkeys and
neither did i
as well as being an integral part to the
cypriot agricultural economy for
thousands of years donkeys were also
used as a status symbol
they were exchanged for land and when
the british occupied this island during
world war ii they used donkeys to
transport weapons and ammunition
cleopatra used to bathe in donkey milk
which was like a very
superstitious thing and
people still believe that it has some
sort of medical properties and so they
make medicinal supplements out of donkey
milk
the cypress donkey has been on this
island for thousands of years
long before machines ever came along to
replace their job
long before the borders shifted and
divided this island and yes while it
seems like there's a large number of
these cypress donkeys here in the north
a recent survey found that there are
only around a thousand
which is far less than the giant pandas
in the world it's less than the amount
of black rhinos in the world and it's
less than the amount of the sumatran
orangutans in the world
so there are real reasons why these
donkeys are being saved and why you'll
go to jail if you kill one
there's simply not very many left in the
world
which again feels a little bit hard to
tell when you're here
but more than being endangered i think
the real reason why cypriots both greek
and turk are so protective of these
animals
is because they represent to them a time
when this island wasn't split in two
a time when everyone here were just
cypriots
in the same way that these donkeys are
not greek donkeys or turkish donkeys
they're just cypriot donkeys
[Music]
and yes
it's also because they're really cute i
mean they are
kind of beautiful animals like i've
never taken a moment to think about
donkeys
look at them
but they are
they are like really kind of striking
animals
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
you